aides on television endeared us to game  show host alex trebek  two years of bravely battling cancer  inspired us  but today there is morning for trebek's  passing the longtime host of jeopardy  died over the weekend after battling  pancreatic cancer for nearly two years  he was 80 years old jeopardy producers  say trebek died early sunday morning his  friends and family were by his side  trebek started hosting jeopardy in 1984  and he discussed his time on the program  during a recent interview with cbs this  morning for 35  years i've enjoyed the success of the  show but i've never really  thought about the impact the program was  having  on american viewers and i become  part of their lives and a bigger part  that was cbs sunday morning  trebek worked right up until his passing  he taped his last shows just a week and  a half ago  trebek's final 35 episodes will air as  they were recorded  and you can see them right here on  channel 8 weeknights at 7.  we're back after this